[تصفيق]
عندما أركض أغلقت
ذهني تمامًا ، فأنا في حالة شافية للغاية ،
فهذا يشبه التأمل النشط عندما
أضع كل طاقتي فيه
أشعر وكأنني في قمة العالم
الاسم هانا جافيا رمال أنا عداء لقد
كنت عداءًا منذ المدرسة الثانوية كنت في
فريق مضمار مدرسة LaGuardia الثانوية ،
فالركض هو مجرد وسيلة للتخلي
عن أي شيء يزعجني وإبعاد ذهني عن أي
شيء يزعجني
.  مريض من الفئة L-3 تم
تشخيصي بإصابة في النخاع الشوكي
لدي كسر في C12
وتحطمت عظامي تمامًا ،
وقع الحادث في سبتمبر من عام 2016 بعد
تخرجي ، وحصلت على وظيفة في فيتنام
لأدرس اللغة الإنجليزية وكنت في طريق عودتي إلى
الفندق الذي أعيش فيه ولكن ضاع قليلاً ،
سألت عن الاتجاهات وأخذني الرجل
إلى منطقة حرجية مظلمة
وحاول اغتصابي دفعت مهاجمي بعيدًا
وعندما بدأ في ملاحقتي التقطت
السرعة وكانت هذه آخر مرة
استغرقت أكثر من ثلاث سنوات
وفقًا لتقارير مختلفة مثلي
هربت منه ، وسقطت على ارتفاع 150 قدمًا من
جرف ، كنت في الهواء لمدة
دقيقة تقريبًا بما يكفي لأخذ كل هذه
الأفكار التي التزمت بها بالفعل
بفكرة أنني لن أعيش عندما كنت
في مستشفى Mount Sinai.
أتجول مع ماشي مع عكازاتي
في سنترال بارك
، رأيت متسابقين خلال ماراثون مدينة نيويورك
، وكنت سأنتبه فقط
إلى خطوات الناس
وكيف سيأخذون هذه القفزات دون عناء ، وأتذكر فقط
الشعور بالمرارة والغيرة
لأنني لم أستطع  لفعل هذه الأشياء بعد الآن ،
كان حلمي هو أن أجري الماراثون يومًا
ما وشعرت أنه بعد الحادث
الذي أخذه مني تمامًا ، اعتقدت
أن أهم شيء يجب القيام به في تلك
اللحظة بالذات هو التركيز على جميع الخطوات الصغيرة
بدلاً من الخطوات الأكبر  الصورة
على الرغم من أنني لا أستطيع تحريك الكاحلين
والقدمين لديّ بعض الوظائف في الجزء السفلي من
جسدي تسمح لي بالمشي والقيام
بكل الأشياء التي أفعلها اليوم
[موسيقى]
لأنه لا يزال بإمكاني استخدام ساقي.
الساقين في مارا
ثون وأنا أريد أن أجري بطريقتي الخاصة ، لكنني
لم أفكر أبدًا في إمكانية ذلك
حتى أرسلت لي أختي
صورة لامرأة تُدعى أماندا سوليفان ،
وهي مبتورة الأطراف وأتمت
سباقات الماراثون المختلفة بعكازاتها.
يمكن أن تفعل ذلك أيضًا
[تصفيق]
26.2 ميلًا هي مسافة طويلة جدًا
لأي شخص ، يجب أن يكون لديك حقًا
قوة الإرادة العقلية هذه في حالتي أنا
هناك لأكثر من 11 ساعة معظم الأشخاص الذين
تعرفهم انتهوا في 5 ساعات يجب أن
أقول لنفسي  سوف أتغلب على هذا
كل شيء سيكون على ما يرام
، قد أتألم الآن ولكن بمجرد
أن أعبر خط النهاية ، سأقوم بالشفاء يمكنني
فعل أي شيء
[موسيقى]
أريد أن يعرف الناس أنه بغض النظر
عن الشدائد التي يواجهونها "  عندما يواجهون
حياتهم ، يمكنهم فقط استخدام ذلك
للنمو كإنسان وربما
يقودهم ذلك في اتجاه مختلف
لم يكن يفكروا فيه عادة
قبل الحادث الذي تعرضت له ، كنت
شخصًا نشطًا للغاية ولكنني تقريبًا أشعر بأنني
كشفت الشدائد ج  أكثر من ذلك
بغض النظر عن مقدار ما فقدته في
حياتك ، فهناك دائمًا مكاسب وهناك
دائمًا شيء
ستنتزع منه إذا
كنت تريد شيئًا سيئًا للغاية ، فستجد طريقة
لاستعادته مرة أخرى  حياتك
مهما كانت
[موسيقى]